(whimsical music)
- I am gonna talk today about identifying
the genetic underpinning of
autism spectrum disorders
and then really wanna
talk about that as really
the foundation for beginning
to understand not only
the biology of these disorders
but also something about
this complex interplay of
environment and biology
that you've been hearing
about throughout much
of the day today.
I'm gonna start by just showing a video
of a child with autism.
Don't worry about the sound.
In fact, it's very hard to
hear but not having the sound,
hopefully, also makes a point.
You don't need clinical
training I don't think
to be able to identify really
what is the sine qua non
of the diagnosis of autism which
is a fundamental impairment
in reciprocal social communication.
So I think you can tell
that this is a young man
who is certainly not typically
developed in that regard.
In a moment, he'll sit
down and start using
a picture board to communicate
and has very little useful
language which is also a hallmark
of those social communication deficits
that is particularly prevalent
in more severe cases of autism.
Also, at the beginning you
saw I believe that he flapped
his hands in the second
domain for the diagnoses.
Those kinds of repetitive behaviors
are highly restricted interest.
So understanding the
genetics of this syndrome,
despite the fact that we've
known for several decades
that autism does run in families,
has been extremely difficult.
We spent much of the
early part of my career
spending more time arguing
about why we couldn't get
the same answer than we
did in being able to lay
a strong foundation for understanding
the neurobiology of the disorder.
Want to talk to you about the
strategy that my lab chose
to pursue, a number of other labs as well,
which was understanding that
there was this very complex set
of levels of analysis
potentially to try to address
from molecule all the
way to complex behavior,
that our thought was that
if there was a possibility
that we could go from the
complex behavior directly
to the molecule, meaning
to get us directly to DNA,
that that could be valuable in
laying sort of the foundation
then to pull on that thread
to be able to get to more
and more complex levels of analysis
and really the whole idea behind this,
I don't think I could've had
a day that had better set up
for sort of laying out
why this was a hypothesis
but the notion that if we could understand
the detailed biology of autism
and other neurodevelopmental disorders,
this could give us the
kind of opportunities
that you've heard about today
with regard to amblyopia
and neurodegenerative
disorders, et cetera.
So, there are many reasons
why we thought that this might
be a reasonable strategy.
Among them is that in some ways,
we had the sense that this was
really the simplest approach
to try to begin to understand something
as complex as autism.
Not a trivial undertaking to try to find
which individual changes
among three billion bases
in the human genome present in
every cell that has a nucleus
in the nucleus but orders
of magnitude less complex,
in my view when I was starting my lab,
than the 100 billion neurons that make up
the human central nervous system
and orders of magnitude still
less complex than trying
to understand the hundred
trillion connections
and you've heard a lot
about synapses today.
So we decided to take this approach.
You could call it really
a reductionist approach
to trying to, as I said,
get at the simplest part of the problem
and then move forward.
We did that starting about
10 years ago by focusing
on something called De Novo mutation.
So when people think about genetics,
they often sort of think
about that as synonymous
with the transmission of genetic risk
from one generation to the other,
from grandparents to parents to children,
but it's also the case as the small amount
of genetic variation is
introduced into the genome
in each generation.
So there is quite a bit of
variation in the human genome.
If you turn to your left or your right,
you are 99% identical to the
person sitting next to you,
level of your genome.
So I hope you got a good seat.
I enjoyed (laughs),
(audience laughs)
I enjoyed mine
but within that, even
though it's about 1%,
that's still 30 million
differences that you have
between you and the person
sitting next to you.
We were interested in de novo
mutation for several reasons.
So the first is that, if a de novo,
if a new mutation which is
introduced at a low rate
into the genome in every
generation is connected
with something like a
neurodevelopmental disorder
to the extent that it
has a significant effect,
over time it will be
eliminated from the genome
by natural selection.
But for de novo mutation,
natural selection has
very little time to act.
So unless the mutation is
lethal in the generation
in which it's present,
you can have genetic
variations, mutations,
that have very large
biological effects and still,
if you can find the de novo mutation,
you're able then to be able to
use that as a starting point
and if you're interested in genetics,
as a way to understand
neurobiology starting
with something that has many,
many fold increase in risk
versus a small percentage
increase in risk.
Seemed like a smart strategy.
This also comported with
a clinical observation
for many years that many families come
to clinical attention,
I'm a child psychiatrist and can tell you
that it was observations
in our clinic as well,
that a substantial portion
come in where there doesn't
appear to be any strong family history,
suggesting that those
families in particular
might have been vulnerable to
the spontaneous new mutations,
de novo mutations,
contributing to their
disorder and then there were
two key papers in 2007 and 2008,
I think the most relevant one
and truly seminal paper was,
the lead author was Jonathan Sebat
who's a professor here at UCSD,
showing that de novo mutations
in fine chromosomal structure
were much more frequent in
kids with autism if they came
from a family without a family history
than any other group
that they compared to.
We then got very lucky
and were able to study
a group of kids in the
Simons Simplex collection
that was designed to
try to help us promote
these kinds of mutations and
this diagram shows really
the experimental design
which is to find families
that look essentially like they'd been hit
by a bolt of lightning where
the blue represents unaffected
and red affected.
So to have unaffected parents
and if there were siblings,
to have them be unaffected
as well and only be able
to have a single affected
member in the family
in order to be able to
participate in this cohort
and then what we were able
to do then is to take a look
and compare the parents to
the children and anything
that was present in the
children that was not present
in the parents was either a
mistake or a de novo mutation
and the second thing that
we were able to do is then
to compare affected children
to their unaffected siblings.
So a beautifully controlled
experiment that allows us
to ask the same question
again that Jonathan Sebat
and Mike Wiggler asked.
I wanna give you two other
kind of senses about why
de novo mutation can be
so powerful to the extent
that it contributes to disease.
The first is that I've
already told you that there
are about 30 million
differences between you
and the person sitting next
to you so you can think
about that as a forest of
genetic variation and, in fact,
with de novo mutation,
I love this picture because
it really represents
about one de novo mutation per generation
in the human genome so out of,
in a section of that,
that codes for genes.
So it gives you very strong
signal-to-noise properties.
You can really identify where that is
and you're counting to very
low numbers and since I,
like Jay apparently, am
mathematically challenged,
counting to one is something
that we've been able to do
in the laboratory.
(audience laughs)
Now the second think is that
this is a big, a large area,
this forest and we have very few events
so we could also leverage an approach
to statistical analysis
that allowed us really
to just ask the question,
if we saw kind of de novo
mutations per particular spot
in the genome,
if we looked at an unrelated child,
could we see lightning striking twice?
So we put those two things together.
This good signal-to-noise ratio
and this idea of recurrence
of these very rare
spontaneous events in order
to identify genes contributing to ASD.
One of the first findings
that we published in 2011,
first replicated what
Jonathan Sebat and Mike Wigler
had done with about 10
times the sample size,
which was an enormous relief, I imagine,
to the entire field given
that psychiatric genetics
had spent many years as I
said arguing with each other
about why we could not replicate.
So replication was kind
of a pop the cork moment
but this finding in particular,
in addition to that,
we were able to identify a
new small region of the genome
contributing to ASD,
Autism Spectrum Disorders,
and that was on chromosome 7
and we found that if you had an extra copy
of the small number of genes
within this chromosomal region,
there are about 25 that reside there,
that you would have
classically defined autism
and look very much like
the child that I showed you
in the first video.
We also knew though that
there was another syndrome
that had previously been
described that was the consequence
of the loss of exactly the same gene.
So autism, there were additional copies,
and in this case, there was a loss
and I'm gonna show you another video.
Here we do need sound.
- Hello, buddy.
How are you?
- I really watch you on ABC news.
- Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
- What's your favorite color
and what's your favorite TV show?
- [Narrator] Kids love to
ask questions but not as much
as these kids.
- My favorite color is blue.
I have met Barney the Dinosaur.
(group cheers)
- Where do you live?
- I live in New York City.
- [Male] Do you have
any sons or daughters?
- I do.
I have two daughters and a son.
- [Male] Wow!
- [Narrator] And kids love to make friends
but not like these kids.
- [Male] What nationality are you?
- I'm Italian.
- [Male] Ciao to you, buddy.
- So that is William Syndrome.
Fascinating syndrome.
We could spend the rest of the talk here
and probably several others telling you
about how interesting that syndrome is
but for the sake of this talk,
what I wanted to point out is that, again,
you don't need any
clinical training to see
the profound differences and
interest in social relations
in affiliation in this
group of kids versus kind
of the example that I gave
you of the first child
where the core deficit is a failure
of that reciprocal social communication.
So when you think about this,
so what we laid out was a
hypothesis that you could go
from a complex behavioral phenotype,
go to the genome and
then work your way back
and I think it would be
reasonable to be skeptical about.
That's a long distance between
a change and a small section
of the genome going through
molecules, cells, circuits,
behavior and brain and
invoking additional things
like environment and experience
but this gave us, I think, a
shot in the arm about thinking
that at least in some cases,
this was a viable approach
because if you do the thought experiment,
if we could understand what
it was about these 25 genes
in the genome or the subset of them
that we're contributing
to this difference,
that you're looking at a
powerful rheostat of something
as complex as social affiliation.
As genomic tools advance,
we're able to move from looking
at segments of the genome,
this fine structure of chromosomes,
to do the same experiments
again at much higher resolution,
now to the single letter
of the genetic code
in all the genes of the
genome simultaneously
and what you're looking at
here is a summary from 2015
that's giving you now a picture
of all of the reliable genes
that we've been able to
identify that are contributing
to autism spectrum disorders,
again with a substantial portion
of these conferring many,
many fold increases in risk.
They're individually rare
in people but in the person
that they exist,
they are having profound
biological effects.
This is Stephan Sanders on the right.
He was a post doc at the time in the lab,
now a junior faculty at UCSF,
brilliant young guy who
led several of the studies
that led to this kind of summary statement
that includes not only our
work but work of laboratories
around the world that have replicated both
the initial observations
around de novo mutations
as well as the specific gene shown here.
So where does that leave us?
Now, we've gone from a situation where,
at least for the first
15 years of my career,
it was like wandering in the desert.
I would've given anything
to find a single gene
associated with autism
spectrum disorder that I felt
I knew reliably and now
we have a series of genes.
There are 60 genes that were
represented in that picture
as well as a number of
chromosomal segments.
So, and that reflects only
a small number of the genes
that we now predict are going to be found
that can contribute to
autism spectrum disorders.
This is a version of a diagram
actually that we put together
with Pat Levitt before the
advances that I've described
for you because they
have been fairly recent
and at the time was aspirational
but has turned out to be
actually I think a pretty
good representation of sort of
where we are and where we're heading.
So the diagram is supposed
to show the same kind
of progression where we have
genes and there are many
of them distributed across
the genome that then underlie
some biology and we hypothesized
before we found the genes
that they would not be
randomly associated but,
in fact, would point us to
specific biological processes
and that has turned out to be the case.
One of the strongest signals that we have
is that these mutations
preferentially target genes
that are involved in synaptic
formation and function.
There are other broad areas of
biology but it's turned out,
you've heard all day about
the importance of synapses
and it turns out that
they are quite important
for autism as well.
That somehow that's mediated
through the developing brain,
this is a picture of the
brain developing in a circle
from embryo all the
way to the adult brain.
Just to remind you that
while we found some biology,
that that biology's being
expressed across development
in the brain and that we
don't go directly from genes
to behavior and that
we know that we're now
about to find genes that
dramatically increase
the risk for autism.
There's some additional
complexities here and one of them
that we found right off the bat
is that while we were finding genes
that were very reliably associated with
a dramatically increased risk for autism,
our colleagues studying
intellectual disability, epilepsy,
and schizophrenia were finding some
of the exact same regions of the genome.
So this presents an important but I think
a not only challenging but
optimistic kind of concept
because you've heard about this notion
of the potential plasticity
and what this tells us
is that even if you have a gene
that it profoundly increases
the risk for autism,
that for some people, you
see nothing for the first 15,
18 years of life suggesting
that genes are not fate
even ones that carry large
risk but somehow that all
the things that we're talking
about today could potentially
be important in determining
how these play out over time
and this diagram shows at
the bottom there that there
are a variety of things
that you could hypothesize
might be involved in that,
epigenetics involvement of the kind
of cellular molecular environment,
other kind of genetic variance
that have smaller effect
but help dictate how these
large genetic risks play out
and potentially for some individuals' luck
but it does also open up this notion
of potential plasticity.
Something I also, that
Mark did a beautiful job
of laying out the three
hypotheses about the development
of neurodevelopmental disorders,
the pessimistic one
and the optimistic one,
and I think it's important
to keep that in mind,
particularly in autism,
something where there's a
large genetic complement
and you see this playing out in very life.
It is also the case that
despite the fact that we are not
anywhere near satisfied
with the treatments
that we're able to provide,
that kids do improve
with early intervention.
Again, I think pointing
to the fact that genes
are not fate and that
beginning to use this body
of knowledge to understand how
this genetic risk plays out
over time leading either to
multiple disorders or not
or improving over time is
something that is quite important.
So I think where we end is that,
this talk at least but hopefully
not in the field (laughs),
is that on the left side of the diagram,
we now have made significant
progress not only
in understanding the genetic substrate
but beginning to define what
the biological processes
are and many labs using the kinds of tools
that you heard about all
day today are now beginning
to place in a developmental
context to understand
the timing of the genetic risk
and how that's playing out.
I think that leads to, we hope,
the substrate to begin to
attack these problems in the way
that you've been hearing
all day that we're attacking
other complex disorders
where the underlying biology
has been more clear than
it's been for complex
neuropsychiatric disorders
and so I want to end by,
as with everyone else, you know,
I get to stand up and give
the talk and have a list
of people who did all the heavy lifting
and particularly want to
point to Stephan Sanders
for the remarkable work that
he's done on gene discovery
and my collaborators
really around the country
who've made this work possible
and can't end without also
thanking not only the funders
but most importantly the
families that contributed
to the Simons Simplex
collection that we were able
to study so productively
for the last decade or so.
Thanks very much.
(audience applause)
(whimsical music)